(whooshing)
(smacking)
- What's up, I'm Destin,
this is Smarter Every Day.
This is the tip of a bull whip
and that crack you hear is this
breaking the sound barrier.
My question is why or how?
Like, if you think about it,
your arm's never leaving your body
and something's going faster
than the speed of sound
in just a few hundred milliseconds
and over several feet.
That's a big deal.
OK, now would be an excellent time for me
to explain April, April Choi.
So April is an engineer
first and foremost.
I think all this whip business
is just a reason for you to explore--
- Fluid dynamics?
- Fluid dynamics.
(cackling)
I really do.
So April on the internet,
you may have seen her,
Guinness Book of World Records whip stuff,
she's good with whips.
But what's really interesting
about April, is your brain.
- There's something in fluid dynamics
known as the no-slip boundary condition.
That means air molecules
that are right next
to this fluffy part stay
next to that fluffy part.
- [Destin] And so, it's
pulling that air with it.
- It depends whether or not you're using
a Lagrangian framework,
which centers on here,
or an Eulerian framework that
centers on the overall mesh.
- That's what I was thinking.
I was wondering if it was
a Lagrangian or Eulerian framework,
but I wasn't going to say anything.
The first thing we did
was create a new tip
for the bull whip and
attach it to the whip
and after that we set
up the camera system.
The way we're getting this shot
is using the schlieren technique,
and this is what took us
so long to coordinate.
Basically, we have a
point-light source right here
and that light is coming
out, it's spreading out,
it's hitting this mirror,
this parabolic mirror,
and as it comes back, what it's doing
is it's converging to
this point right here.
You can see there's the
light coming through
at the focal point.
And then we've got red
and green gels right there
and (whip cracks).
(laughing)
That's scary.
Go watch Derek's video on schlieren,
it's better than this one.
We're just gonna show you
how a whip breaks the sound barrier.
That is unnerving.
After everything was set up,
we literally got crackin'.
(whip cracks)
OK, that triggered.
Let's see what it did.
We learned two major things
in my buddy's garage.
First a question, though.
What point in the whip extension
do you think the crack happens?
Growing up, I used to
play Castlevania a lot,
so for me, it made sense
that the crack of the whip
would happen at full extension of the whip
'cause that's what you want to
do with the bad guys, right?
You want to keep them as far
away from you as possible.
When we set up a high-speed camera
expecting the whip to crack
like it does in Castlevania, the shockwave
would always enter the field
of view before the whip did.
(thundering)
Therefore, it was clear
that the crack was happening
before the whip was fully extended.
So it's cracking way back there.
- It's cracking before we think.
- I learned something.
I didn't know that.
- Yeah.
I didn't know that either.
- It actually happens as the whip unrolls,
not at the end like I thought.
And in order to visualize
what's happening,
we switched from the overhand strike
to the sidearm strike.
What you're about to see
here are two engineers
that have researched this stuff
and were totally blown away
because the experiment worked
and we're starting to see
things for the first time
that we totally didn't expect.
OK.
We are getting somewhere.
(laughing)
(whooshing)
(thundering)
(snapping)
The second thing that
we learned in the garage
is there may be a
mechanism that's causing it
to accelerate just before
breaking the sound barrier.
(whip cracks)
Those strands right
there are not in tension.
You see that?
- Yeah, they're just, it's chaos.
- [Destin] And then there's this moment--
- [April] Where they all come together.
- [Destin] Where they all come together
and when it starts to pull,
that's when the initial shockwave starts.
- [April] So it's the collapse.
- [Destin] The collapse
is when it happens.
- [April] And the drag
coefficient's going down.
- The fact that we're
seeing a new mechanism
is a really big deal.
So obviously, we have to
take this more seriously.
We just figured out how whips work.
We should totally publish this.
- Yeah.
- Whip shockwaves have been studied
from the experimental
perspective in Germany in 1998
as well as the theoretical perspective
at the University of Arizona in 2003.
The Ernst-Mach Institute
paper, by the way,
freakin' amazing.
There's a dude in it that looks
like a moose wearing
bells and a clown suit.
(laughing)
I don't know what's happening.
It's actually a great paper.
You should totally read it.
They talk about wishing they
had a faster high-speed camera
so they could see what happens at the tip.
Also, the paper at the
University of Arizona,
they try to measure with math
the entire length of
the whip as it unrolls.
They try to describe that movement.
But what if we could design one experiment
that would do all of this?
Like all of it at the same time.
It would measure the
three-dimensional position
of the wave as it goes down the whip.
It could also measure the tip velocity
as it goes supersonic.
What if we could do that?
And that's exactly what we're about to do.
Under the guidance of my doctoral advisor,
Dr. Kavan Hazeli at the University
of Alabama in Huntsville,
we've assembled the team and we're about
to figure this junk out.
We designed the experiment
and gathered together
in what's called the atom lab.
It uses an array of cameras to track
anything with reflective tape on it.
The way it works is essentially this.
You have a camera and you have
a little infrared light around it, right?
If you have a piece of
reflective tape out there
and you shine the light
from the infrared camera
onto the reflective tape, it
bounces back to the camera
and it shows up as a really bright dot.
So we simply put reflective
tape around the whip
every 250 millimeters down
the length of the whip.
We also put reflectors on her arm
so we could better understand
the mechanical input to the whip.
The image from one
camera would essentially
be an array of white dots
at 500 frames per second,
but if you coupled this data with the data
from other cameras, you can triangulate
each individual segment of the whip
at 500 frames per second giving you
true three-dimensional data.
OK, here we go.
This is the kind of data we
can now get from a whip strike.
- [Man] Three, two, one, go.
(whip cracks)
- The footage you're now watching
is 5,000 frames per second.
You can can that the Vicon
cameras up on the wall
are taking data at 500 hertz,
which means they're
flashing every 10 frames
on the high-speed camera here.
You'll notice that the
whip unrolls normally,
very similar to how the paper
from the University of Arizona
described it mathematically.
Let's make a few observations here.
First, there seems to be a wave
that moves down on the whip.
As the hand moves forward and then stops,
it transfers momentum
into the whip itself.
Then, one segment of the whip,
as it unrolls and straightens out,
seems to transfer all of its momentum
into the next segment,
and then the next segment
and so on and so forth.
As indicated by this red line
moving along the bottom here,
you can see the velocity
of that straightening out
of the whip moves forward.
We can then look at the atom lab data
and measure the input
momentum in three dimensions
and use that information as a
tool to help us build a model.
So the whips coming up towards the mirror.
(muffled mumbling)
That's awesome.
Is that awesome?
- Yes.
- Another thing to look at
is what's happening on
the top of the whip.
The velocity is speeding up.
Most researchers think this has to do
with the conservation of momentum.
The whip is tapered so
each smaller section
on the way down has to speed up
to maintain the same amount of momentum.
This is the exact reason we
took so much time up front
to measure the mass and
dimensional properties
of the whip all the way down.
This is where it gets
most interesting for me.
If you look closely at the atom lab data
you'll notice that right
at the tip of the whip
the markers seems to disappear
right when the whip accelerates.
This is because the
trackers lose the position
of the whip markers when
they're traveling their fastest.
Even if the atom lab
didn't lose the track,
you can tell that the
frame rate of the atom lab
isn't sufficient to
determine the acceleration
through the most interesting
part of the wave,
which, of course, is the shock formation.
This is exactly why we set
up the schlieren camera.
The atom lab gets all
of the wave kinematics
on the macro scale and
then the phantom can record
the tip velocity and actually capture
the formation of the shockwave.
(light guitar music)
(whooshing)
I'm not gonna explain any of
our preliminary conclusions
but at this point we're
doing two types of analysis,
obviously how that wave propagates,
but also the tip velocity of the whip.
If you watch closely,
it looks like the tip's
getting pulled along
behind that shockwave.
This is super complicated and
we're still analyzing this.
(whooshing)
(smacking)
What we do know is that
the popper isn't necessary.
Dr. Kanistras really
wanted us to visualize
the end of the whip with only a knot on it
and just look at how happy he was
when his hypothesis was proven correct.
- There you go.
There you go.
- So it's like this.
For the first time in history,
we have true X-Y-Z data
from the handle all the
way to the tip of the whip
and we can straight up write
an equation for whip dynamics
as a function of mass of the whip,
length of the whip, mechanical input,
maybe even aerodynamic drag.
I know this sounds crazy,
but I'm already changing
my habits in everyday life
because I understand whip dynamics better.
Have you ever done this?
You're in your car, you
reach for your charging cable
and you pull it towards you real quick
and it whips you really hard?
That hurts like a mother.
The reason that happens is whip mechanics.
I cannot be the only person in the world
that's ever done that.
You don't want to just pull it quickly
because that conservation
momentum builds up
and you get lashed in the face.
So bull whip was probably
the first manmade invention
to break the speed of sound.
But my favorite manmade invention
to break the speed of sound was the SR-71.
This is not an SR-71, this is the A-12,
the predecessor to the SR-71.
There are 13 of these built.
I'm now going to simulate
running to the back
at the speed that this aircraft can fly.
Ready, watch.
That was fast wasn't it, OK? (laughing)
I'll go back and do it slower
and tell you about the
aircraft on the way.
OK, we're back at the front.
So, I want to tell you about Audible.
Audible is sponsoring this video.
There's a book called Skunk Works.
You can get a free
audiobook of your choice
by going to audible.com/smarter
or texting the word smarter to 500500
to get any audiobook of your choice.
In this case, your choice is Skunk Works.
I've already made your choice for you.
You have to listen to this book.
It's about the development of the SR-71
and the F-117 stealth fighter.
I'm sorry, I just passed
the hot naughty bits.
Look at this.
So think about the shockwave.
As you're going mach
3.3, which this could do,
think about what happened.
The shockwave would go right
there and it'd spread out.
But you had to get air
inside the cowling there.
It's amazing.
Anyway.
Go to audible.com/smarter,
download Skunk Works,
listen to it with your ear holes.
You're gonna love it.
This thing would heat up in flight.
They had to make it out of titanium.
All kinds of cool stuff in the book.
I just want you to go
to audible.com/smarter,
download Skunk Works, or text
the word smarter to 500500.
You're gonna learn stuff,
it's gonna make you smarter
and you're gonna know more about
breaking the sound barrier.
Um, I have two blasters and if I fire
the one that you're
thinking about right now,
feel free to subscribe.
Or not, whatever.
Ready?
(sirens blare)
(chuckling)
They're on the same thing.
That's a, they cycle...
(sirens blare)
See, but now they're not.
The gap in my data is spacial.
I'm not gonna get any of that.
And the gap in your data is temporal.
- Right, yes, you're right.
- [Destin] But with our powers combined,
we're gonna track a whip.
- [Man] Right, the fact that my (mumbling)
is accurate position.